tropical storm durian is barreling
toward the Caribbean this morning it
could hit Barbados tomorrow and Puerto
Rico by late Wednesday tropical storm
watches and warnings have been issued
ahead of the storm CBS News climate and
weather contributor Jeff Berra deli is
tracking durian Jeff is a storm on track
to hit Florida and what can the impact
be for Puerto Rico yeah so it's possible
towards the end of the period maybe next
week and it could threaten Florida but
in the near term it's the Lesser
Antilles and yes Puerto Rico that's a
look at the storm big blowup of
thunderstorms in the other Center the
storm is now stronger than it was last
night
winds are 60 miles an hour moving fairly
quickly at 14 so during the day tomorrow
it will impact the Lesser Antilles winds
65 miles an hour the big day for Puerto
Rico is going to be Wednesday could
become a cat 1 hurricane Puerto Rico is
in the cone and also on the stronger
side the eastern side of the system so
even if the winds aren't very strong the
rain could be very strong we could see
potentially some bad flooding there then
the question is how much survives as it
heads towards the state of Florida and
into the Bahamas as we head into next
weekend a lot of the computer models
agree with this general track it has a
lot of Hoops to jump through to get
there intact but it's something we need
to watch closely and lastly on the
mainland big line of showers and
thunderstorms today Oklahoma and also
Missouri severe weather wind gusts up to
70 miles an hour and we'll be following
a tall thank you Jeff